Final Fantasy 15 has released at long  last but Square Enix isn't done with it  yet I'm Tony and this game spot news  update has more content on the way  director Hajime Tabata released a blog  post discussing the team's plans for  improving Final Fantasy 15 now that it's  out first on the list the infamous  chapter 13 will be enhanced with buffs  to the magic ring and other gear after  that the team wants to improve the story  with new cutscenes and sequences that  better explain character motivation in  the long term Tabata wants to add more  playable characters and even a god mode  all of those updates will be free and  the game's first paid expansion the  holiday pack is likely releasing soon a  second pack plus some side chapters for  gladiolus ignis and prompt dough are in  the pipeline after that to keep up with  all the news from final fantasy and  Square Enix you're already in the right  place  you